2020 has already seen some netflix
originals get lots of positive buzz
from drama series to gripping
documentaries the streaming giant is
experimenting with plenty of fresh ideas
with their release schedule ramping up
more than ever it's inevitable that some
gems will fly under the radar
there are medical dramas there are cop
shows and then there's medical police
which combines both genres into one
comedy series
medical police is basically a spin-off
of the adult swim series children's
hospital
and just like children's hospital it
pokes fun at all kinds of classic tropes
you've seen on other medical shows
lola we've got trauma trauma sounds like
my lucky day
in medical police dr lola spratt and
owen maestro become responsible for
dealing with a deadly virus that has
been released in cities around the world
they race against time as dangerous
players plot to expose even more people
to the virus and their adventures take
them around the world
the writers never miss an opportunity to
squeeze in another joke and the series
is heavy on meta humor
if you found yourself laughing at
children's hospital before don't miss
medical police
you'll get to spend even more time with
these hilarious characters and see them
dealing with entirely new and wacky
scenarios
in the taiwanese drama the victims game
we're introduced to fang yi jin
a future forensic scientist with
asperger's syndrome eugen is a great
student and he never misses a detail on
his assignments but his lack of social
skills means that he endures bullying
from his classmates
years later yijn is a working scientist
and he's assigned to a horrifying murder
case
a once popular singer has been killed
and her body has been dissolved in acid
making it difficult to positively
identify the corpse
as an adult yi jen doesn't always fit in
with the rest of his team at work but
his work ethic and keen eye mean that he
often notices things that others don't
and this case is no different
after ye jen takes fingerprints from the
singer's belongings he's shocked to find
that they match a print found on one of
his daughter's old drawings
yee jan has been estranged from his
daughter for years partially because he
was so focused on his work
now he knows he needs to find her so he
enlists a local journalist to help track
her down
and find out how his daughter became
entangled with this murder mystery
if you're a fan of police procedurals
you'll definitely get invested in the
victim's game
in extracurricular jisoo is the ideal
high school student
he studies hard gets perfect grades and
never causes trouble in class
but outside of school his life isn't so
perfect his parents aren't around and in
order to support himself and save up to
attend university one day he's had to
work hard
but he's not clocking in at a typical
part-time job with the help of his
business partner mr lee he's secretly
running a prostitution ring
of course jesus finds that he can't keep
his double life a secret forever
he's got a crush on his classmate and
when they both end up in a social issues
club together at school he's excited to
think that he might have a chance with
her
but when she notices that he carries two
cell phones she instantly becomes
suspicious
what happens if she blows jesus cover
jisoo is willing to do almost anything
for money but the antics of this teenage
anti-hero just
might blow up in his face when jokora
lincoln was growing up the last thing he
wanted to do was follow in his father
jd's footsteps
jd's involvement with local gangs in
oakland always jeopardized their
family's safety and jakkur dreamed of
becoming a rapper and carving out a
better life for himself one day but as
you'll discover in all day and a night
jacor's path ends up taking a dark turn
after finding out that he's about to
become a father he tries to make some
money by working for the wrong crowd
and his actions land him in prison for
life in the same prison
jd is waiting for him behind bars when
father and son come face to face once
again
jakkor ends up on a journey of
self-reflection don't do like me
be somebody like your mother said he's
had to figure out which decisions have
led him to end up like his own father so
that he can break the cycle for his son
this gripping drama is anchored by
powerhouse performances from ashton
sanders jeffrey wright regina taylor and
yaya abdul mateen ii
the narrative and i'm no longer here is
presented in a non-linear structure but
the story is so engaging that you won't
have any trouble following the plot
ulysses a teenager living in the slums
of monterey mexico
is the leader of the los turcos game
which embraces a counter-cultural
lifestyle known as colombia they spend
most of their time going to dance
parties and showing off their attire
but the party comes to an end when
ulysses witnesses a drive-by murder
carried out by a rival gang
a survivor threatens ulysses telling him
that if he doesn't stay away his family
will be hurt
when his mother finds out what happened
she fears for the safety of their
household and she arranges for elise to
be illegally smuggled into the united
states
ulysses ships off to queens and as he
struggles to find his way in a city
where he doesn't know a soul it becomes
clear that his quest isn't just about
starting over somewhere new
it's about holding on to the identity
and culture that he left behind in the
midst of it all
loosely based on the polish science
fiction novel the old axolotl by yatsek
dukai
into the night is the first belgian
original series on netflix
sure you've probably seen plots about
plane hijackings play out on the screen
before but chances are you've never seen
anything quite like into the night
passengers on board a red-eye flight
bound from moscow from brussels are
shocked when their plane is hijacked by
an italian soldier
he demands that the pilot depart early
warning the crew that if they don't take
off soon the sunrise will kill them come
morning
the passengers are understandably
confused and frightened but the pilot
abides by the hijacker's threat
to the horror of all on board they soon
find out that the hijacker was telling
the truth
countless people have been killed in a
global crisis brought on by a deadly
exposure to sunlight
now the passengers and crew must
continue chasing the darkness until they
can find refuge
every high school student has their
secrets but in control z everything that
the students at this school have tried
to keep hidden is about to be exposed
this eight episode mexican series proves
successful enough that netflix has
already ordered a second season
so now is a perfect time to catch up
during a school assembly a hacker gains
access to the school's computer system
and plays a video that targets popular
student isabella who is instantly
embarrassed when her deepest secrets are
suddenly up on screen for the whole
school to see
but when the hacker offers isabella
revenge she takes the opportunity and
other
students turn against each other when
their secrets are suddenly out in the
open
sophia herrera an introverted student
who happens to be a keen observer tends
to notice things that others miss
and now she's determined to use her
observational skills to do a little
digging and find out just who this
hacker
is after all she doesn't want her own
secrets revealed to the entire school
and the only way to do that is to expose
the hacker first
the french action thriller lost bullet
kicks off when lino an exceptionally
skilled car mechanic ends up behind bars
after he drives a car
right through a building he survives the
crash but his seatbelt jams and the cops
get to him before he can bolt
his time in prison takes an interesting
turn when he's presented with an offer
that he just can't turn down
a cop asked leno to become part of a
rather unorthodox work release program
in exchange for reducing his sentence
and he'll need to put his mechanic
skills to good use
naturally lino agrees the rest of the
film is a wild ride and the action
scenes are so engaging that you'll have
no problem accepting the absurdity of
leno's situation if you're familiar with
the famous juwon franchise known
stateside as the grudge you might
already know the premise of juwon
origins
when someone dies while harboring
powerful rage a curse is born and their
spirit haunts the place where they died
no one is safe from their desire for
revenge juwon origins is the first
original japanese horror series on
netflix and it functions as sort of a
prequel to the other entries in this
franchise
the series takes place over several
years following an ensemble of
characters who are affected by a
lingering curse at the scene of a murder
a curse with an especially traumatic
effect on pregnant women and families
with young children
the storyline in juwon origins brings
new depth to these legends but fair
warning this series is exceptionally
violent and gory with graphic visuals
that are not for the faint of heart
but horror fans who can stomach it can
easily binge watch this series in a
single spooky evening
this belgian drama series follows 12
citizens summoned for jury duty their
job to determine the truth behind a
harrowing case
a woman has been accused of murdering
her daughter and best friend and now
this jury must try to evaluate the facts
the 12 isn't just about the murder
itself the characters also have to
separate their own pasts and lingering
guilt over mistakes they've made from
their feelings about the case
it's clear that their personal histories
cloud their judgments
the people assigned to this jury are
imperfect and deeply flawed but they've
been tasked with the responsibility of
discerning the truth
the series poses interesting questions
about our legal system and the validity
of calling in a jury to weigh in on a
verdict
maybe this system is the best we have
but this show will make you question how
we can ensure that justice is really
served
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite netflix originals are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one